MALE SPEAKER: Becky Herbert from
Herbert Farms, and Joe Morris,
from Morris Beef, and Lisa
Knutson, who provides chickens.
They work with Eating
with the Seasons,
who are here to talk about the
community-supported agriculture
that they help
provide to Googlers.
And they'll talk a little
bit about maybe their farming
methods or history, and
we can open up the Q&A
after they all talk.
So, thank you.
Welcome, Becky.
BECKY HERBERT: I have
a basket of berries
that I'd like to pass around,
if you guys want snacks.
The first of the
blueberries this year.
So, thanks, Mark, for having us.
I'm excited to be here.
We have a nice little
community developed at Google
and have been there for years.
So, it's always exciting to
come and meet the members
and interact with them.
So, as Mark said,
I'm Becky Herbert.
I'm the owner of Eating
with the Seasons.
We're a family-owned
business that
is based in
Hollister, California.
How many of you are
familiar with the CSA model?
So, quite a few of you.
So, you know that
the traditional CSA
is one where you
subscribe to farm
in exchange for a
weekly box of produce.
And what I've done with
Eating with the Seasons
is I've taken the
model and evolved it
to where we're actually
a multi-farm CSA,
and we let people choose what
goes into their box each week.
So, you never get
what you don't like.
So, our mission
with the CSA is just
to supply healthy,
nutrient-dense produce
to our customers and
just connect busy people
with their food and the
people to produce it.
These days everyone so busy
it's really hard to really pay
attention, but my goal is to
make it simple and convenient
and fun to know your farmers.
So my dad started
the CSA in 2000.
His name is Pat Herbert.
He's a fourth generation
farmer in Hollister.
And his CAS was the
traditional model.
We had 50 members in Hollister
who just got his box of food
each week.
And a couple years into his
venture, I was in publishing,
and I got kind of bored with
doing the publishing business.
I didn't think it was going
to be as boring as I found it,
so I ended up joining
him at the farm.
And it was supposed to
be a temporary venture
to help him market his produce.
And, as it turns out, I
found a lot of my colleagues
at Chronicle Books,
where I used to work,
and Sierra Club,
where my husband was,
interested in the CSA, so I
just started delivering to them.
And it was a lot of people that
were my age, you know, mid-20s.
They didn't really
cook, but they
liked fruits and vegetables.
So they were kind
of picky or didn't
know about kohlrabi or a
lot of the winter squashes.
So, I ended up just
creating a system where
I sent a list to
them and they told me
what they wanted in their box.
And it became so popular
that the colleagues
that I was working
with, they started
spreading the word to a lot of
different companies in downtown
San Francisco.
And we just started a delivery
route in San Francisco,
and it really has become
the pace of Eating
with the Seasons-- the model.
And we've just
expanded over the years
to different companies
and community drop sites
all over the Bay Area.
So we've been going strong
for 12 years doing that.
The basis of my dad's farm
is to build the soil, make
a nutrient-dense layer, to where
his fruits and vegetables have
a higher nutrient content.
And he uses a
compost method that
was developed by the
Lubki family from Austria.
They basically took
the biodynamic farming
and expanded on that.
It's a very complex,
scientific recipe.
I'm not a scientist, but
he uses clay as the base
and a lot of recycled
materials from the area,
like dairy waste and things
like that that stick together
in the clay.
And then he puts
it into the soil.
And that actually creates a very
hydrated systems in the fields,
to where he doesn't have to
use a lot of water, which
with the drought now is really
helping him be able to grow
a lot of food when some people
can't if they don't have water.
So, that's been the
basis of the farm.
And he ended up having
some health problems
a couple years into helping,
so he had to cut back his farm.
He couldn't grow the 50 fruits
and vegetables for the CSA
anymore, so I just took that
as an opportunity to reach out
to our other farmers
in that area who also
use the same composting
method and just
have the same values of
nutrient-dense, high quality
food.
And so Phil Foster was our
natural first approach,
because he grows over 250
different items every year,
which is amazing.
He was all for the CSA, so
he's kind of our main vegetable
supplier now.
And we have a lot of
growers that are small.
They do one or two
commodities a year.
Those strawberries and
blueberries I have here
are from Francisco
Serrano, who's
a main grower for Alba
Organics, which you're probably
familiar with.
But we buy directly from
him, whatever he has.
He also has very
high-quality food.
So, as the years
have progressed,
I've just really expanded what
Eating with the Seasons offers.
Any kind of food that is
local, organic produced,
that we like the taste of
and we think our customers
will be excited about, we
just start partnerships.
So for example, we just
discovered Suncoast Organic
Farm, and they're literally
15 minutes from where we are.
They have wonderful olive oil.
I think it's the best I've had.
And there's a lot of
olive oil produced.
It's kind of like a
new trend to grow.
But theirs has a grassy
element, but it's
very user-friendly
to cooking, as well.
So, we started offering
that, and what's
great about them is
they're not into the profit
so much as getting healthy
olive oil out to people,
so the price is lower than what
you would traditionally see.
Some of the higher ends sell for
like $22 for 500 milliliters,
and we sell for $15.
So, big difference.
So, that's the gist of how
Eating with the Seasons
has evolved to where it is.
We have a lot of plans to just
keep evolving over the years.
We want to also add a
kitchen to our business
to where we have pre-made meals
that our members could have.
Just after talking
to people, they're
so busy that a
lot of people just
don't have time to cook
as much as they want.
So, we really would just like
to find all the different ways
to produce food that
people will just
have nutrient-dense food
instead of going to In-N-Out
Burger on their way home,
they can give their family
like a jar of soup.
So, that's kind of the
direction we're going.
So, for now I guess I'll just go
over the basics of our program
and how it's
structured, and then I
will introduce my
two wonderful farmers
that have joined me today.
So, we have four different
membership sizes.
It was developed to appeal to
the single person, all the way
the family, or someone
who juices a lot
and just requires a lot of food.
We have an extra
small, for example,
that's six fruits and
vegetables for $19,
and it goes all the way
up to 16 items for $49.
And the more you pay in advance,
the more you get a discount.
So, we have some members who
subscribe for the whole year,
so you get 4% off
your membership.
And then you can also add--
we have an extra strawberry
option.
Because they're so
popular, we like
to offer that during
the peak season, where
you get three clam-shells of
berries for $8.25 in addition
to your order.
And you can also add
weekly or biweekly eggs.
So, we work with a couple
of different farms,
and Lisa from
Pasture Chick is here
to talk about her practices.
But first, I'd like to
bring Joe Morris up and talk
about his grass-fed beef
and land stewardship.
JOE MORRIS: Well, thank you
Becky, and thank you, Google,
for showing up and taking
some time of your lunch time
to be with us and talk about
the wonderful world of food,
at least as Becky and I know it.
And Lisa.
And Jack-- my son
Jack is also here.
So, I thought I'd kind of
start out with an introduction,
and then tell you a
little bit about how
Morris Grass-fed works
relative to our customers,
and then talk a little
bit about the purpose,
overarching purpose.
Because food touches
us at the dinner table,
but it also can touch a
vast experience of life,
starting at the kitchen
table and moving up
to the carbon cycle
itself in the biosphere.
So, my name is Joe Morris.
Morris Grass-fed Beef is the
product of TO Cattle Company,
and TO Cattle Company's been
our family's ranching enterprise
for five generations.
And I actually grew
up in San Francisco,
but I always loved the life
and the work of a cowboy.
So I always sort of
tended toward that.
Every vacation I had I
would head to the ranch.
And when I got out of college,
I was told again and again
that you just can't make money
in the livestock business,
in the cattle business.
So go do something
else, and have
some cows on the side
or something like that.
And I thought, well, I either
have to do things differently
than the best people I
know who are doing it,
or I have to give up my dreams.
And that wasn't
acceptable to me,
so I decided I would
do things differently.
And so we did.
We've learned about management
of land and animals and people.
And then we had
this beautiful beef
that we were producing,
beautiful animals.
In the conventional
way of ranching,
those beautiful animals would
stop doing their wonderful work
on the land and be sent
to a feedlot, where
they were sort of helpless
to do any good at all.
And you create
all these problems
when you divorce
the relationship
between the animals
and the land.
And they become feedlot beef.
And we didn't really
want to do that.
We saw some problems with
the industrial food system,
and we wanted to kind
of shake the foundations
in our little tiny
way, and involve
all the people that we knew.
My wife Julie and I both
grew up in San Francisco,
and we wanted to
become sort of liaisons
between the land and
the processes there,
and the people we grew up
with and associated with,
and friends, and so forth.
And so we started
Morris Grass-fed Beef.
We started direct marketing
our beef to families and people
like you.
A couple years ago-- our model
has expanded over the years--
and a couple years ago, we were
buying Herbert Family Farms'
CSA.
And we met Becky, and we
decided to kind of put our heads
together and see if we do
what we do well on the ranch
and be supported by
and support what Becky
has done so well to get
beautiful food to customers
like yourselves
around the Bay Area.
And so we've been
working with Eating
with the Seasons for several
years now, and it works well.
Some of your coworkers
are our customers.
And basically what
is this is, we
provide what we call
a split half, which
is a quarter of a beef--
one side of a beef divided
into two equal parts
that contains steaks,
from filet to New York
to rib-eyes to roasts,
from o-bone roast to chuck
roasts, short ribs, shanks,
and ground beef.
So you have a diversity of beef.
All of it is wonderful.
But it comes with a
caveat that it requires--
I was talking with Mark a
little bit-- it requires
a little bit of
energy, forethought.
The good thing-- it's
your energy, which
comes from the sun
and the food you eat.
And so it's an
interesting experience,
besides being nutrient-dense
and a wonderful support
of other values that are
embedded in that meat.
And so our purpose is to
bring all of those values
to our neighbors.
And those values are from food
to clean air and clean water.
And all of us know that
we can go our entire lives
without super high quality food.
Human beings have
adapted to do that.
And that's not a goal,
but it is a reality.
But we can only go a few days
without really high quality
water.
And water is one of those
problems around the world where
there's not enough of it.
It's not diversity.
It's not decentralized.
People are trying to control it.
People fight over it.
So, water's vital.
You can only live
last a few days.
And oxygen, of course, we can
only last few minutes without.
And so our management of the
land and animal relationship
touches all three
of those things.
We can produce beautiful food.
If we manage our land
and animals well,
we can manage that enormous
force called photosynthesis.
And by doing that,
we can do what
Becky's dad is trying to do and
move carbon from the atmosphere
into our soils, which does all
the good things that moving
carbon out of the
atmosphere would do.
It can be done by people
such as me, very low tech--
although we do use Google Earth
to help us kind of visualize
and monitor our management.
But it can be done on range
lands around the world.
And range lands constitute
45% of the land mass.
So, there's a huge potential for
management of that carbon cycle
that can do only good
things for all of us.
Puts carbon in soil,
builds the soils capacity
to receive and hold water, which
decentralizes the water system,
produces wonderful food and more
products from ranches and farms
like Becky's dad
is trying to do,
and keeps people on
the land, because they
are producing more.
Our system, after the
animals leave the land,
is to work with artisan
butchers, small-scale family
operations, who take very
good care of both the animal
while it's in their
care for a short period,
and the food itself.
They know how to cut it.
They're great
partners, because we
don't know everything
there is to know.
Two heads are better than one.
And a good butcher's
head with ours
and Becky's makes a great
experience for the community.
We'll be around for
questions, but I
think I'll stop there and
let Becky and Lisa take over.
LISA KNUTSON: Hi.
This is really fun.
My name is Lisa Knutson.
And I'm not five generations
like my friends here,
but I grew up in a home where
my dad was a law enforcement
officer in the days when
their income was very little,
and we were a family of six.
So my life started
with growing animals,
planting gardens,
raking the horse manure
and thinking it was
a really good time.
My dad had that ability
to create that for us.
We packed the manure,
we'd put it our ground,
and we'd leave it to get
rained on all winter long.
The spring would come.
We hand-spade it-- or he would.
We'd have to pull the weeds.
We'd produce a garden.
We'd grow beef.
We'd grow lamb.
We'd grow chickens.
We grew turkeys.
We grew rabbits.
We did all of this.
And somewhere along
the 18 years old,
I decided that, I am
so fed up with this.
I'm leaving.
So I went to beauty school,
and I became a hairdresser.
And I had a salon
for 12 years that
was voted the best
in our community,
and we really
popular in the '80s.
Yeah, we had all the hair.
And it was just embarrassing
when you look at it now.
But about 10 years into
that, I started getting ill.
And It got to the point
where I stepped back,
and I let my staff
pick up my client base.
And it changed our
world financially,
but I realized that the
environment that I was in
was really probably
starting to kill me.
And so I left.
And I was hiding and alone
for about five years.
And we had a
godmother at the time
who had land that had been in
their family for generations.
And it'd been leased out by the
same family for generations,
but they were now aging.
And my husband said, you know,
Glory, when that comes up,
we'd like to have it.
So we waited 10 years for
our first piece of land.
And I had left the salon,
and I had done odd jobs.
I recreated myself,
I think, maybe
five times in three years.
And had many
different positions.
I did a lot of marketing work.
And then we got the land.
And so we had known Joe,
and my dad had grown cattle.
And so I purchased my
first 20 red heifers.
And we started producing
a grass-fed natural beef.
We didn't go direct
sales like what Joe did.
We just produced it
on a commercial level.
And then we started
looking at the land
that we had and realized
the type of income
that we needed to develop
on the 200 acres that we had
wasn't sustainable.
The land had been
dry-farmed for hay,
which means they sucked
everything out of it.
It grew a beautiful
crop of star thistle.
I mean, my poor horse.
I'd go to move
cattle, and his legs
would be just bleeding
from poke marks,
because the star thistle
had become so dense.
And so the other downfall that
we had was our little ranch
was about here, and there was
all these other bigger ranches
around us.
And I don't know if you've
ever been around a bull
when he wants to go
where he wants to go.
He just goes.
And mine included.
So we always had this
problem of animals
where they didn't belong,
limited amount of income.
And so one day, I just told
my husband, I said, you know,
I think there's got to
be a better use for what
land we have that can
change our income.
And so we sold our cows.
And I had bought
maybe a few Merino
sheep and some cashmere
goats, because I
thought spinning
would be really fun.
You know, making yarn.
I said, I think that
we can impact the land
and do a better job
economically for us as a family
if I go to a smaller animal.
And so he was agreeable.
So we made this big change.
And over the next
couple years, I just
grew the flock to
200 mothers, and I
was able to impact
the land really well.
We partitioned it off.
We rotate and graze.
But we just kept having trouble
with some parasite issues
with our sheep and our goats.
And I thought, you
know, I think we
need another species in here.
And I told my husband, I say,
I think I want to grow chicken.
And right along the
same time with that
was not just what I
thought the chickens could
do for the grass,
but at that point,
I'm buying chicken
and going, we could
be eating tofu for the
flavor that this chicken has.
I remember chicken as a kid
what real chicken tasted like.
When you talk to French
people or European people,
they're just like,
you guys don't
know what chicken's
supposed to taste like.
So, I told my husband, I said,
I want to grow some chicken.
And the eyes rolled up in
his head and it was like,
you know, you've really gone
off the end on this one, girl.
So I started growing
chicken for us.
I wanted to put a few
out on the pasture
to see what it would do
to the grass dynamics.
And I never thought
that we would
be doing what we are doing
today, which is we rotate out
300 meat chickens
every other week.
We've got 1,700 hens
that are laying eggs.
Our grass is amazing.
The star thistle-- I feel super
bad, because the bees don't
do very well out there anymore.
They have to go
further for food,
because what used to be
200 acres of star thistle,
we now have perennial
grass coming back.
And it's been amazing to see
what a multi-species grazing
program can do on the land.
So, now we have this
product-- so I'm
trying to give you the
whole ranch picture.
So Becky is our local girl.
I heard about her a couple
of years ago, and I thought,
I'd really like
to meet this girl.
And over time we got introduced.
And she has really been key
in helping small farmers.
Because we're small.
We have approximately 300 acres.
And we're producing
chicken, eggs,
and then pasture-raised
organic lamb and goat meat.
In the fall it's harvested.
But how do you keep up, and
how do you find you guys?
I can't be running
around doing all of that.
So we have people
like Becky, who
she's become my friend
and my business partner.
And our goal is to just
continue to not become
this big huge entity--
like my farm is never
going to be a big farm.
Joe's farm is never going
to be this oversized farm.
Small family farms
that can take the time
to grow you really
good food, Becky's
the vehicle that we
can use as a team
to see that our
produce and our meat
get to the people who really
need it, and don't have
the same opportunity
that we have to grow it
and to produce it.
So, that's kind of just the
brief nutshell of what I do,
and how it came about doing it.
And I think like Joe said,
I think I can stop there.
And then if you guys
have questions, I mean,
I'm really OK with
anything you might
want to know about what we're
doing or why we're doing it
or what's involved.
Is that good, mom?
[LAUGHTER]
BECKY HERBERT: Thank you.
Does anybody have
any questions for me?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, I have a few.
I was wondering if each of
you could talk a little bit
about-- like, how do you
tell that the soil is getting
better?
Are there scientific
tests you run
that show you that there's
more organic matter in the soil
and things like that, or
you just kind of look how
much better the grass is this
year, or look how much better
the produce is, or the
animals, things like that?
BECKY HERBERT: No,
there are tests.
My dad does them every
two to four years.
It kind of depends on where
he's at with his compost.
And if he has
potential customers,
he'll run the tests
again, if there's
like a new-- he
sells compost too.
I don't know if
I mentioned that.
So, he always has an
idea of how much--
at this point, since the
early '90s, every few years,
it goes up 1%.
And I can't remember
what the UC system says
is the highest organic matter
you can have in your soil.
It might be 3%.
And the last time he
tested it, it was at 5.6.
So, it's almost
like the UC systems
are at a point where
they're like, how
is that even possible?
But he's really just
started doing it every year.
Since 1989, he's been
putting the compost in.
It's kind of become
a religion for him.
So, yes, there are tests.
There's different
tests you can run
to get what different elements
are in there, and how much.
If you go to his website,
there is information on it.
If you actually want to
study his whole process,
it's
herbertfamilyorganicfarm.com.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
LISA KNUTSON: I
would say, for me, I
don't have a
scientific test I do,
but you can look at plant
placement-- [INAUDIBLE]
And we're just
like, it's not true.
The goats love it.
They-- I watched them
one day as we put them
into a fresh
pasture. [INAUDIBLE]
And they go straight
for the star thistle.
And they eat up the stem,
they turn it around,
and they eat backwards so that
the little pricklies fall off.
So, now that we've
poisoned that star thistle,
we have grass that's a
little bit more beneficial.
And the placement of
the plants is closed,
versus we have
perennial grasses that
never could start until the star
thistle had been cleared off.
Because if it
stays-- I don't know
if it's that way
everywhere-- but just looking
at my place and the garbage,
when there was star thistle,
the little perennial
grass was so covered over
it couldn't come out.
Now that we have that cleared
away, I'm having more range
grasses start to
come up. [INAUDIBLE]
And that's how I judge that it's
doing better, because there's
just a lot more feed available
that's across-the-board better.
The sheep aren't as big
on star thistle as goats.
Goats are totally into it, but
sheep are more-- [INAUDIBLE]
JOE MORRIS: Well, I don't
know if it's better,
but I think it's an
absolutely a great idea.
And this is where [INAUDIBLE]
and I get together
on this thing, because
measuring soil carbon has
been a challenge, because the
soil is extremely diverse.
And one carbon sample from
here, the soil's organic matter
sample is not-- this
little square meter
can be very different
from this square meter.
And so there've
been a lot of tests
that kind think of how do we
monitor soil carbon to know
whether our [INAUDIBLE] are
increasing it or decreasing it,
and what does that mean?
And so there's a lot of
different things happening
in that regard.
And I'm part of a group
called Soil Carbon Challenge.
It's a friend of
mine who decided
that, you know, how do
we know these things?
How do we know how
to run a fast race?
You run the race.
You don't do all these
extraneous things.
You just get people out
there and run a race.
And he started this
whole carbon challenge.
And it got around
the world, really,
but mostly in the United States.
Measuring, taking readable
measurements of soil carbon,
and getting measurements of
carbon from around the world.
[INAUDIBLE] Great guy.
Soil Carbon
Challenge. [INAUDIBLE]
The other thing is that where
Google comes into play--
and he should be here, because
he's way smarter than I am.
He's really a brilliant guy.
But one of the
things that Randy can
do to know whether their
soil is improving or not,
is a simple test of
measurements of productivity.
In other words, you have
one ranch next to another,
and they're basically the
same sort of productivity
to begin with, you can measure
the animal days per acre
produced on this ranch,
versus the animal
days per acre on this ranch.
OK, so it's the amount
of grass-- or amount
of animals that can
feed for one day
on an acre, which is about
the size of a football field.
So, if you can get 10 from
this acre and 30 for this acre,
it's a huge difference.
And that can be
measured fairly easily.
My friend Peter
Donovan is really
interested in remote sensing.
Because what we're really
doing by testing those animal
days, days per acre, is
looking at the productivity
of the land.
When the productivity
of the land increases,
the hypothesis is, that
the way that happens
is because the soil is
increasing in organic matter.
When you have increased organic
matter, you will water more,
and you create more
food and opportunities
for life in that soil.
And most of the species
[INAUDIBLE] on Earth,
are beneath the
soil, not above it.
And so if we can get
more life in our soil,
we get more and better
food from our soil.
If you know anybody who's
interested in those ideas
and would like to have more
in-depth conversations,
let me know.
AUDIENCE: You were saying
it's not [INAUDIBLE]
JOE MORRIS: Well, in
ranching, it happens.
You have a certain number
of animals on a ranch.
Say it's 85, 100, 1,000.
And you have 100 acres.
And you know that
those hundred cows
can eat on those hundred
acres for 30 days.
AUDIENCE: And are you
dividing that land up?
JOE MORRIS: Well, it depends.
That's a management option.
So, if you have 30
days-- or each animal
on each day for-- 30
times 100 is 3,000.
And you can have that 100
cows for 30 days there.
If you're introducing
new management practices
on another 100 acres, you can
increase that 3,000 to 4,000.
You can increase
it by [INAUDIBLE].
Now, we can look from
satellite, and we
can measure the productivity
by measuring greenness
over time on large areas.
Then, we have good feedback
on management techniques
and practices [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh, great.
Oh, thanks.
Thank you.
I really have enjoyed this.
This has been
really interesting.
I actually just signed up for
a membership about a month ago,
so I'm really enjoying it.
I'm actually on the food
team here at Google,
and I understand that
when this was set up,
it was totally independent
of the food team.
And I was just curious
if you or anyone else
could speak more about
how this CSA got set up,
and how many Googlers
are involved with it,
and how much it's
grown each year.
That would be really
interesting to hear.
MALE SPEAKER: So, I
might be the best person
to try and answer
those questions.
My name is [INAUDIBLE],
and I am a person who
coordinates with Bruce, one
of two people [INAUDIBLE]
set up and maintain [INAUDIBLE].
I inherited the role
from Cynthia Young,
who I believe set it up.
I don't know how
she got started.
I don't know what
drove her to do it.
Basically, it was kind of
fully formed and [INAUDIBLE].
These days, we
have-- I think we're
going to be 40 or 50 active
members receiving [INAUDIBLE]
on a weekly basis.
The number fluctuates,
but that seems
to be a constant, a
steady-staying number.
Was there anything
else that you asked--?
AUDIENCE: Well, which
of the memberships
is the most popular,
or is it pretty wide?
MALE SPEAKER: I couldn't say.
So, one of the things
about the way we work
is that we only
provide the space.
Any local members keep up their
own relationships [INAUDIBLE]
seasons.
So, Becky, I suppose, might
be in a better position
to answer that than I would.
BECKY HERBERT: Sure, yeah.
Most people probably do
the extra-small six item.
What I find that--
you know, we deliver
to a lot of different
companies in the Bay Area,
and I always use Google as an
example, because the customer
base are the people that
take advantage of purchasing
an array, not just produce.
They subscribe to Joe's
quarterly Morris Grass-fed Beef
deliveries, they
add eggs every week.
I don't know.
I always was curious to know--
is it an educational thing?
I never knew how you
guys promote it here,
except like Cynthia used
to send out-- every season
she would send out emails to
get more people to sign up.
And I don't know if
that's still happening.
MALE SPEAKER: I personally
haven't done anything
like that.
I should probably
investigate and find out
what I'm permitted to do.
One thing we have
here is we have
a lot of different
interest groups.
And so there's a
bit of consideration
as to spamming the
entire pile of Googlers,
particularly those
who don't really care.
I'll take it as an
action to figure out
what the right promotion
is, but right now, it's
either word-of-mouth, or
there's an internal site listing
the various perks and
services that people who look
might happen upon.
So, it's all because of chance.
Speaking of which, I don't
know if it's been mentioned,
but for anyone here who's
interested and hasn't already
signed up, we have a
site that's go/csa/mb.
And that's go/csa/mb.
And right now, [INAUDIBLE].
It's got all the information so
far as signing up, logistics.
For instance, we probably
just had delivery happen.
If it's not just
happened, then one
that's probably in
progress right now.
And go and have a look
and take it from them.
BECKY HERBERT: I also have
postcards with my website
where you can sign up.
If you want to take a postcard.
MALE SPEAKER: Pretty
much you'd sign up
on their site, [INAUDIBLE] to
have either here or [INAUDIBLE]
BECKY HERBERT: I can also speak
to-- when we started, Cynthia
approached me, and
she was looking
at a few different CSAs,
and she ended doing a poll.
And that's how we
picked up the slot.
She did a poll of like,
what would you prefer?
Which farms?
People just recommended us.
AUDIENCE: So, [INAUDIBLE]
So, obviously you guys
are [INAUDIBLE] Could
you just describe
some examples of trying to
get other people [INAUDIBLE]
out to the community to
encourage better practices,
but then, at the
same time, maybe it's
just we're supposed to let
other people [INAUDIBLE]
based on our dollars
and spending.
You have any other
recommendations or advice
for [INAUDIBLE]?
putting the practices into
larger population [INAUDIBLE]?
JOE MORRIS: Our business
started 22 years ago,
and it had two families-- our
friends that I was constantly
[INAUDIBLE] Today, we
have over 900 families.
So, I don't know the best
way to get these practices,
because practices
are tricky things.
When we're working
in biology, we're
working in an incredible
number of variables.
And what's sort of best
practice on one place
may not necessarily be
sustained in another place.
There's some principles, but
[INAUDIBLE] A friend of mine
says the best practice is
monitoring, at least when
you're dealing with
biology, because then you
get that feedback, then
you know in this place,
doing this will
yield such-and-such.
But, as far as getting the
attractiveness of this food,
I think there's a big thing
that consumers-- you know,
our customers-- can do.
And that is [INAUDIBLE].
Feed it to your friends.
Talk about it.
And talk about why.
The values of buying
in really good food
go far beyond just good meat.
And that's a very
sort of selfish kind
of way of thinking about food.
And then going towards
this land [INAUDIBLE]
So, word-of-mouth.
Word-of-mouth is absolutely
the best way of doing it.
And I don't know--
others [INAUDIBLE]
LISA KNUTSON:
[INAUDIBLE] But, we've
taken the time [INAUDIBLE]
We have a little book.
This was taken literally about
two weeks before it rained.
This was the [INAUDIBLE], this
was the chickens right after
[INAUDIBLE] These
are meat chickens,
and people come up to
me, because we had a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LISA KNUTSON: [INAUDIBLE] OK.
I mean, I've [INAUDIBLE]
and I watched
that, it broke my heart.
I mean, it broke my heart.
Because [INAUDIBLE]
I've been in livestock,
I've been in produce,
but I had no idea.
I had no idea.
And it's people that
are in [INAUDIBLE].
Honestly, I tell my husband,
how did we live without Google?
Because I can't think of it.
If I can't figure it out, I
go to you first, and I'm like,
what happens when?
[INAUDIBLE] And I know how
to take care of livestock.
And so you come to me
at farmer's market,
and I get this
question all the time.
And I had a lady last
week walk up to me
that is, well, why is
your chicken better?
Why is your chicken
better for me?
And first I told her, I said,
I don't know that it is.
I don't know that.
But if you're looking
for a chicken that
has a life that's
different than this--
this is the new standard
for cage-free eggs.
I belong to the
California Farm Bureau.
They posted this.
And I covered up
the farmer's name,
because he's really
excited, because those
used to be battery cages, which
these poor little hens were
stuffed in there, and
they just eat and lay.
But this is the new cage-free.
So when you see eggs
that say cage-free,
that's what you're thinking of.
But then you see-- what did
I do with the other one?--
then you see pasture-raised.
So, you talking-- I think you
guys are what's moving it,
faster than what
Joe and I are doing.
Joe and I just happen to--
we had a teacher in common.
There's a man-- and his TED Talk
was really good. [INAUDIBLE].
And he talks about the mistakes
he made, but then Africa.
And what happened to the
biodiversity of the land,
and what happened
to the river basin,
and what happened to the people,
what happened to the animals.
When I heard him 30
years ago, he really
jerked my heartstring.
Because if you're a gardener,
if you plant something,
you take care of it.
So his thought to me was, the
grass is what's important.
If you don't have grass,
you can't do this.
you can't do what Joe does.
And Joe does rotate
his pastures,
and I rotate my pastures.
And you watch your
garden-- like if you're
doing-- what's the
grass that you juice,
that everybody likes to juice?
AUDIENCE: Wheatgrass.
LISA KNUTSON: Wheatgrass.
OK.
If you cut it too short the
first time, you're done, right?
You just lost the $10 or
whatever investment for your
[INAUDIBLE].
If you cut it the
first time, and you
leave life in that
grass, it's common sense.
Don't wipe it all out at first.
Take a little bit, juice it,
take care of it, watch it grow,
take some more.
So, what we do
with our animals--
this last year was tricky.
We went from 100 mother
sheep and 100 mother goats
to 40 a year ago February.
Again, I just [INAUDIBLE]
watching plants,
but we had so little rain.
And what do you know, we
didn't get that follow-up rain
that we needed so bad.
So, I watched those plants.
They went to about this high.
I didn't graze it all off.
If you watch-- well,
Joe was talking
about sections of ground,
and here's one piece,
and this piece looks different.
We call it [INAUDIBLE].
If you look at our
ground, and you look
at our neighbour's,
it's totally different.
We have grass.
And then when we're
getting into the fall,
I will take the grass
down about like that.
Just do not mulch little plants.
Do not protect those,
so when the rain comes,
there's some cover
there so they can
get established
and take off again.
That's our practices.
But, it's people like
you that go, oh, look.
I just met this guy.
I can't believe what he's doing.
And you talk about it.
Because now, in a little more
central market-- [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
These people, they care.
People that care about animals,
people that care about us.
This is our livelihood.
People that care about what's
going to happen to the ground.
They talk.
And so, from the first $100
that we get in six months,
they talk to enough
people, and now it's $500.
And I'm equating it in
dollars, but dollars
represents the
word being spread.
I have people come
up to me now--
we've been in Mountainview
at the farmer's market
just since the Sunday
before Christmas.
I had to get rid
of my cowboy boots
and go to Converse, because my
feet hurt so bad, because it
is on the full time.
So, what are you doing?
So why are you doing this?
How do you know how much
GMO is in your feed?
Where are you sourcing this?
And then they go and tell.
I come the next
week-- oh my God.
My friend was just telling
me blah blah blah blah blah.
We have to have your chicken.
Not just because
it tastes amazing.
It's different.
The eggs that come in
that box-- don't try them
unless you want an addiction.
It's not like anything
else you've ever had.
It's different.
And I'm convinced-- the
more the farmer hears
about the animals--
it's a pastured chick
ranch, because
it's a girl, right?
It's a girl's farm.
And I love on everything.
It is important how these
animals are handled.
I was taking their picture.
Hello!
Are they cute or what?
They [INAUDIBLE] like that.
But when you watch
the fence line,
if you move the cattle--
I can guarantee you,
when Joe's ready
to move pastures,
those cows are waiting for him.
Because they know
[INAUDIBLE] It's that way.
And what we do--we're
telling you, now,
you go talk to some more people.
Then, you're going
to help support us,
and then our peers--
who are typically
governed by only the dollar--
think, well, maybe there's
something to that.
Phil Foster.
He's my big brother.
He has been-- there aren't
even words for how good
he's been to me.
His wife and he started with
20 acres at most, years ago.
[INAUDIBLE]
He's so special.
My emotions were
in the way, sorry.
But he started with 20 acres.
He's now almost 300
acres in two ranches.
We share a ranch in
Santa Ana valley.
The man that comes and
inspects his fields,
he's a professor at [INAUDIBLE].
He brings his class out
and makes field trips
at the farm, and stuff.
And he told me-- he was
out checking the plants
and he goes, I need
you to know how
you've changed Phil's farming.
And I'm immediately going,
oh, God, what did my dogs
do, or did the goats
get out, you know?
He goes, the pests are
down, the noxious weeds
have come to a halt, the
ground squirrels are managed.
In this book, they did
a story about my farm,
and we use these huge dogs.
And you guys can have these.
I brought them for you.
I don't know if you
can see that very well,
but if you pass
that around and you
look in with the
sheep and goats,
there's dogs of equal size.
So, I've told the coyotes,
you can't eat here.
But, I do have something
to recreate what they do.
What do they do?
They hunt the ground
squirrels everywhere.
We don't have an overpopulation.
We haven't killed them off.
They're still there,
but they're managed.
Just like how the
coyotes would be.
Same thing with the rabbits.
And that's what Doug told me.
They're losing less
produce, because I've
replicated a natural environment
with my sheep-- it's not
going to eat my
sheep, but [INAUDIBLE]
But, it comes back to you guys
talking about people like us.
Someone like Becky,
who's willing to be
the face of all of us farmers.
It's huge what she's doing.
And my gosh, you should have
her coffee and the honey.
Oh my goodness.
And that olive oil
really is the best.
Did you tell them about
what else she's doing?
BECKY HERBERT: No, I haven't.
LISA KNUTSON: Is it a secret?
BECKY HERBERT: No. [INAUDIBLE].
LISA KNUTSON: OK, well I'm going
to tell you the rest of it.
So this girl-- the [INAUDIBLE]
-- I show up at Mountainview.
And I go walking, because it's
a long ways to the restroom.
And I'm looking at all
this, and I see, what?
The South Side Road?
She's 10 minutes from my house.
We didn't know
each other existed.
So, she has taken
this olive orchard,
and she's put in
those brick ovens.
She's baking bread
that she grinds
the organic grain herself.
She uses her olive oil.
She makes bread that
you can't believe.
And she was right
in my backyard,
and I had to come clear
over there to find her.
And so she's going
to [INAUDIBLE].
But she's [INAUDIBLE] going
to help Joe and I stay.
Because the practices that
we do, they're a lot of work.
It's a lot of work, and to
have someone that is out here,
attracting the view to what
she's got going for us.
Because it takes a lot
of us to get this going.
If you talk about
what you heard today,
it's going to drive the
people that are only
looking at money to start
looking at doing things better.
The pride is worth
more, and people
do pay more, because they
know how much time it
takes for us to produce that.
That make sense?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So, if I may interrupt,
we are starting
to run out of time in
the hour. [INAUDIBLE]
But, for those of
us like me, who
have official things that
we have to do at noon,
I just wanted to bring things
to a close, and [INAUDIBLE].
But I want to thank
Lisa, Joe, Jack, Becky,
Mark, for setting all of this
up, you guys for coming down.
Thank you so much for coming by.
It's been amazing to
hear you guys talk.
Please join me in a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]